STEPHANIE WONG: Machine
learning is everywhere you look,
and it's made up of
different pieces.
When building a
model, you may not
be thinking about the
infrastructure needed
to train and serve it, and
that's why Kubeflow exists.
Let's talk about what
Kubeflow is trying to solve
and how you can use it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Kubeflow 101.
Today, we'll be giving an
introduction to Kubeflow.
If you want to check out
the documentation directly,
check out the link below to
read more about Kubeflow.
Now, when it comes to
maintaining machine learning
systems, it can be especially
challenging to manage
all the application, platform,
and resource considerations.
ML apps have a
different footprint
from other web or
mobile deployments.
For example, a training
phase is resource-intensive,
while an inference phase
is lightweight and speedy.
You'll also need the
tools and frameworks
to run all of these pieces.
Existing solutions that are
great for building applications
in other domains don't capture
the nuances needed for ML.
So Kubeflow is all about
creating a standard
for deploying enterprise ML
apps, not just development
or production, but
the entire lifecycle.
Kubeflow is an
open-source project
that contains a curated
set of compatible tools
and frameworks specific for ML.
One of the primary
goals for Kubeflow
is to make it easy for everyone
to develop, deploy, and manage
portable, scalable
machine learning.
It may not surprise
you to hear it's
built on top of Kubernetes,
an open-source platform
for running and
orchestrating containers.
Kubernetes is built
to run consistently
across different
environments, and this is
key to how Kubeflow operates.
Let's talk about
three principles
that Kubeflow is built around,
composability, portability,
and scalability.
Composability means that you
can choose what's right for you
on your project.
People starting out
in machine learning
tend to be focused on the
end result of the model,
but there's more than
just building a model.
The process that goes into an
ML project has many stages,
and each stage is made up
of different building blocks
that you choose.
It shouldn't matter if you
have special requirements
for your ML
workflow, like if you
need to use different
versions of TensorFlow
for different parts
of your project.
Kubeflow extends
Kubernetes' ability
to run independent
and configurable steps
with machine-learning-specific
frameworks and libraries.
Portability means you can
run all the pieces of your ML
project anywhere you're
running Kubeflow.
So it handles the
platform specifics,
and you can just
focus on your model.
Write your code once, and let
Kubeflow handle the abstraction
so you can run it on your
laptop, an on-prem training
rig, and in the cloud.
Scalability means
your projects can
access more resources
when they're needed
and release them
when they're not.
Every environment can have
different computing resources
like CPUs, GPUs, and
TPUs, but you may also
need to scale across teams
and running experiments.
Kubeflow leverages the
abilities built into Kubernetes
to maximize available
resources and scale
with as little manual
effort as possible.
So if you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
you can probably
see how it enables
Kubeflow to do all of these.
But there's also a
lot of complexity
in knowing how Kubernetes works,
which can require expertise
in many additional concepts.
Another option may be
hosted ML offerings,
but that may not work if
you have on-prem hardware
requirements.
Kubeflow is designed to let
Kubernetes do what it's good at
and allow you to focus
on defining and running
ML workflows, including
managing data,
running notebooks, training
models, and serving them.
It's also open-source and
has a growing community.
Now, that's a pretty high-level
overview of what Kubeflow is.
In the next video, we'll
go through setting it
up and running an example.
But you can also try it out
for yourself on Google Cloud
by checking out the
link below and visiting
kubeflow.org to read more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]